ever phillips is with me very good
morning to you Trevor I mean let's start
with that those numbers they're fifty
five against twenty three monks PME vote
is for remained what do you put that
down to is a lot of it down to the
leadership of the leave campaign morning
government I don't think so I think
there are two basic reasons why people
from minority backgrounds will favor
remain first of all intuitively they're
more global in their outlook and the
first thing they're going to think is we
live in a rough world and actually we
need to be part of a big group to be
able to compete with China and America
and by the way one of the things that I
think is very important is that
particularly in the Commonwealth
governments from countries in Caribbean
Africa and then just say we need Britain
in the EU because you are a gateway to
this market of five hundred million and
I think that weighs heavily with people
and the other point I suppose I would
make is that if you look at who's lining
up for us to leave it is true that most
of the people involved in that campaign
most people who support it across Europe
are people who are not that keen on
immigrants or immigration I should say
and that intuitively I think most people
from minorities will say well these
people don't really want us here and
actually if we were to leave who are
going to be the people who are most
likely to be not denied job
opportunities in the e in the EU without
Britain Germany France and so on it's
gonna be people whose ancestors weren't
born in and there's an argument from
some leave campaigners not cut any ice
which say well you know if we were able
to limit migration from within the
European Union then it would be an
opportunity to to treat the rest of the
world in a particular Commonwealth
countries more fairly when it comes to
to immigration well look you know people
from people call it pretty smart I mean
these people people like my parents
traveled a long way in hard
circumstances to get here to have a
better life they're not easily taken in
so when somebody for example like my
friend Nigel Farage says look you know
this is going to be much better for
people from
Commonwealth the question I want to know
is what did the brexit people think it's
gonna be like on the other side do they
really mean that we're going to shut out
a quarter of a million new migrants and
then instantly admit a quarter of a
million people from Pakistan or Nigeria
I really want to hear Nigel tell his
supporters that that's what he means by
brexit haven't heard it yet but you know
I'm wait I'm up for it but I mean it
must be said Marian afterwards report
don't weigh that term you know like like
all communities in the UK there are
concerns about numbers there are
concerns about pressure in particular on
public services by numbers well I don't
think there's any question about that
indeed people from minorities themselves
are just as tough minded on the question
of immigration immigration numbers but
the question is would breakfast help us
know because the reason we've got a lot
of immigrants is because we have a
vibrant economy that needs people to do
the jobs particularly in the public
service we know that actually all the
economists tell us that in fact it's not
a drain on our economy but it does
create issues to do with infrastructure
schools railways and so on and the way
to solve that is by investment in those
services and particularly by the way by
putting more money into training of
people who are born here because that's
a real problem that's I think that's the
thing that really scratches with people
whether they are white or not white
recent immigrants or not but somehow
there are clever polish or
Czechoslovakian young people coming
getting jobs and our young people aren't
getting the opportunity the answer to
that is not brexit the answer to that is
better training and and the the broad
point whatever your views are in
whatever community you can't express
them at the ballot box unless you
register to vote though there's a big
portion I wasn't it amazes the where
this is the absolutely big thing we want
to make sure that everybody whatever
their point of view everybody gets out
there and expresses their opinions and
it's important for minorities to feel
this isn't somebody else's business it's
not on that poster it's a bit
stereotypical isn't it you know this is
well let me be perhaps utley honest this
is not the poster I would have chosen I
think what they're trying to do is to
provoke people to come out and vote good
intention maybe not the greatest
execution all right Trevor great to see
you ever thank you very much D Trevor
Phillips there